Let's see. This one seems to be clearly not equal to à.
This is a huge angle--greater than 90 degrees.
But I do know that this angle is identical to à.
The reason I know that--well, they're opposite each other,
so that's always going to be the case that opposite angles are identical.
But let's talk about why.
If I examine this entire arc here,
I know a straight line--well, I've made half of a circle here,
so this is 180 degrees.
This angle here is some à degrees--
I don't know what that is--which means that this angle marked in red
must be 180 - à.
Now, since this line here is also equal to 180 degrees,
this segment of it is 180 - à.
This segment must also be equal to à.
But that's not so interesting.
What I care more about is this angle here,
which also happen to be equal to à.
Again, we can talk about why.
Let's extend this line and this line a little bit.
Now we have these two parallel lines.
The black line here is parallel with this purple line up here.
We can go through this same sort of thinking to prove that this angle is à,
this one here is 180 - à,
this one has to be à, and then this one over here would be 180 - à.
But this is what we care about.
This angle here is identical to this angle here.
Now we're making some real progress.
Let me clean this up a bit so we can see what's going on.